YouTube I often talk about how my mom
crushed it you know I talked about
writing a book called perfectly parented
you're about to watch a video that talks
about that in detail but ultimately I
believe the biggest myths in the world
is people focusing on things that don't
matter and under estimating the things
that matter this story may confuse many
but at the end of the day focusing on
the things that matter most and building
up self-esteem around that and then
suffocating and muting the stuff society
values because in reality long term it
doesn't matter as much that nuanced
landing that plane is what my mom did
phenomenally phenomenally phenomenally
watch this you're so confident so sure
of yourself but when you were just
starting my mom your mom my mom what she
do feel when I was nine years old and
opened the door for an elderly woman at
a McDonald's she reacted as if I won the
Nobel Peace Prize what my mom did was
super smart she overreacted on
everything that I was doing that was a
good human trait and she held me
accountable for things that didn't
matter like grades my mom built huge
self-esteem in me and I feel like the
biggest reason I am Who I am today to
everybody is cuz I feel so guilty and so
grateful for what she did for me that I
want to do it for everybody else
which is guess what you suck at a ton of
good so does everybody else you also
probably pretty rad at something tries
many things as possible until you figure
out what your rad at and you like and go
do that for the rest of your life and
stop giving everybody else
[Applause]
got off that often Thanks
she is
[Applause]